all right so how many people are new to
programming here anyone couple people
this is kind of a talk for new people
but even if you're not new I think it
could help seasoned developers too so
this is becoming a better programmer
without actually programming let's see
and obviously you have to do some
programming to become a good programmer
I mean but when I jumped into
development four years ago I
accidentally kind of stumbled upon an
invisible step at least for me so my
name is Ryan Johnson I'm a graphic
designer
and software developer at my consulting
group ice after college I spent about
six years as a professional graphic
designer and about four years ago I
started working for this company in my
consulting group and became a full-time
developer which is quite a switch at the
time everyone told me you know do
tutorials think of an application you
want to make and create it and I kept
hearing the only way to learn to program
is to actually program and so you know
like everyone else I used you know
Pluralsight codecademy w3schools you to
me things like that even took some
classes at a triple C and you know that
honestly I you know optima t' the large
a large chunk of the process is
developing so it makes sense
you know unfortunately I'm not up here
to like with some kind of you know nerd
upload I can give you all instead i kind
of the missing ingredient for me was i
became good friends with my co-workers
and i spent a lot of end up spending a
lot of time with them and then that i
kind of found my missing ingredient and
for me that was full-on immersion and
just by being around people that loved
programming and talking about
programming with people i store i sort
of started to absorb things and you know
even even things that whenever my head
at the time eventually came back around
and I understood them just thanks to
talking with developers and and also
developers seemed to have this like
obsession with development almost and it
kind of gets infectious a little bit you
know when I first started as a graphic
designer I thought development seemed
cool you know programming was wow you
know I didn't think I'd ever be able to
do that so it seems so smart and it was
kind of scary and the more I got into it
though and got around people who enjoyed
it it it kind of eased that for me as I
said coming from the world of graphic
design it was all about you know our
language was Apple computers Adobe
skinny jeans and it was it was it seemed
simple to me but I've done it all my
life I guess then I jumped into the
world of development and all of a sudden
it sounded really scary at first you
know words like the DOM and dak Pak and
even windows I didn't use Windows in a
long time so and then some weird terms
came about too like one of my first few
months and development someone asked me
would you rubberducky for me and I was
like no
weird and even under the covers I have
so many arguments with my co-workers
because to me it should be under the
hood but in the development world it's
under the covers for some reason which
just sounds weird to me so so with that
hearing all these terms and stuff I kind
of realized that it's more than just you
know hello world and if statements it
and like I said it first it freaked me
out but the more I kind of got to
talking about these of people it
I started getting relaxed and my big
thing was I just I asked questions no
matter what no matter how dumb it seemed
for instance you know one time someone
was talking about the view in sequel and
I had heard the view and as a you know
part of the front end and so I was like
in my head I'm thinking I must be dumb
so I finally asked I was like what what
is the view and sequel I don't
understand and once I once they
explained to me that it's you know this
procedure type thing I understood it but
I think a lot of people are afraid to
ask afraid to discuss things and I think
it's important that you don't do that
and like in a lot of these terms to when
the first time I heard DAC back I didn't
even want to sound scary even when they
explained it to me it didn't make sense
but now that I use it you know did
monthly I guess it's not like something
you touch all the time but I it came
back around and it's like oh it was
familiar and so it wasn't as scary the
next time I'm gonna kind of relate this
my idea here to playing guitar because I
started playing guitar 11 years old
something I've done all my life I
remember even back then I made the
conscious effort to always be holding my
guitar because my feeling was guitars
are awkward there's just this big piece
of wood with strings I mean they're
they're not comfortable and so you know
yeah I still had to learn chords I still
to learn scales I still had to learn
songs but just by holding that guitar
all the time when I was watching TV when
I was
you know emailing someone whatever which
annoyed my wife you know which annoyed
my family I mean just I'm always holding
my guitar it's a constant but because of
that I became really comfortable my
guitar and eventually got better and
better and to me that's relatable to
this you know immersing yourself in that
world you just pick up things that and
you get comfortable so that when those
different ideas come around it's no big
deal
and that kind of brings me to you know
the next side of this just because like
I said I'm four years in and I'm to me
I'm still new I mean that's but I can
already tell that I have to keep
learning or else I'm gonna forget things
and it doesn't just mean keep learning
the one thing you do you know if you're
a c-sharp developer it don't just focus
only on c-sharp I feel like it helps to
learn other languages and other even
things that you think you will never
touch if it's technology related somehow
it always comes back around it seems
it's like in the four years I've done
this I'll hear things that I'm like I'm
you know elixir for instance I'm never
gonna work on a lick sir
well now I'm doing a side project that
is a lick sir and so and so with user
groups you know that I know we're all
here for c-sharp
but I want to why not try some other
groups tried Ruby or try you know you
know whatever just look at what would
interest you and it helps you make
friends in the industry and I think
that's an important thing to do because
you get discussing things outside of
work and it can teach you new things
that you never even thought you would
need and it could come up on the job so
and then that goes along with learning a
technology don't work that you don't use
a work and then also like I said I'm
doing a side project right now creating
you know create a side project either
alone or with other developers I think
that's important because you you only
learn so much on the job you know you
you get kind of a lot of times you get
doing the same thing and so
you know for me I'm mostly from than
half the time and so I'm making these
views over and over well that's gonna
that's gonna make me just kind of become
stagnant if I just do that
so I met some friends and started
working on a side project that's angular
6 and elixir and you know functional
programming that definitely is a term
that would have scared me at the
beginning but I've been to some user
groups and heard about it and why not
let's try it you know and you know the
other thing that I often hear with from
people is that come up and do these
talks they'll say they they learned a
new skill just to give a talk it was
just kind of giving a talk as an excuse
to learn a new skill and I think that I
mean what a better way to force yourself
to learn something you know go sign up
or something like this as nerve-wracking
as it may be and next thing you know you
know this thing that you didn't think
you would have otherwise and or maybe
even thought you didn't have time for
otherwise so again ryan johnson do you
guys have any questions yes thank you
sorry okay what's dad pack
I'm not the best person to answer this
question I feel like but you know what
this will here's a good thing to do now
so since you don't know what that is
let's do a talk on it so in our next C
sharp lightning talks we can expect a
talk on backpack come back for that one
the other question
okay so the question was how D what's
the best way to get over being afraid to
ask questions and then the second part
of that was how do have us the best way
to not sound condescending when you're
answering I don't answer a lot of
questions so I don't know about that one
but even with that one I can only say
it's like when people ask me stuff with
graphic design I mean I'm just because
I've been doing it for a long time
doesn't mean I'm the best at it and so I
always try to keep that in mind that
there's people way better than me and
I'm reminded of a constant one you know
I think mine is logo design was awesome
and I'll get online and see someone else
doesn't be like I suck but that's that's
part of it so I think if you keep that
in mind it's easy to answer questions
that way and the first part of that
question how do you get over the fear of
asking questions
I mean you if you really want to be good
at something you just you're gonna have
to look dumb but even though if if you
know even though it feels like you're
looking dumb I I think to those people
it feels like you're being intelligent
by asking a question so I don't think
there should be a fear and also
developers love to talk about the things
they know they love to show how smart
they or something so it's not gonna you
know it's not gonna make you look bad at
all so another question
right
so Ruby on Rails when was it this
Thursday yeah 11:30 so come to that and
you can learn a new skill like I was
saying yeah rubber ducky yeah so I can
explain this one basically you know how
a lot of times you'll be working on
something in code and you just you know
it but you just can't get it so you'll
call someone over and they'll be your
rubber duck they won't say anything
you'll just look at them and explain
what you're doing and somehow it comes
to you every single time so some people
use actual rubber duckies I guess I
don't know it still seems weird to me I
usually call it rubber goosing